what have you seen just believing in
somebody due to their confidence it
uplifts them and it motivates them we
had instance on the sideline this last
game where Jimmy was having a horrific
game he's a receiver Jimmy horn and I
said Jimmy you're a dog we from Florida
man and guess what Pap is at the crib
and he's incarcerated watching you right
now and he wants to clap in front of all
his different inmates Because he
believes in his son we gonna make pop
proud tonight that's what we G to do
because his son is a dog now you go out
there and show the world who you are he
went and caught the touchdown the game
tying touchdown just speaking life into
Jimmy and understand where he was I've
been there because I sympathize and
empathize with him and I know his
background and his situation so I'm able
to pull that intangible out of him that
I connect to him in a pivotal time like
that